la prison côté gardiens sans
propositions pour l'améliorer résultat
les surveillants grogne déjà et le
ministre se fâche
la chute de la maison strauss nerfs
30,50 dictature le général tout puissant
a été destitué un bain de sang 100 morts
au microscope ce soir la ville de lille
avant les municipales tout sur la
bataille politique tout sur l'enjeu
économique
tennis coupe davis france un israël 0
mais le conte est en difficulté face à
mende d'or match en cours
au tableau d'honneur ce soir une escale
à 2 de la 21 ans elle s'appelle
pâtissier quand elle grimpe c'est un
régal
bonsoir mais tout d'abord ce dramatique
accident ça s'est passé dans l'aisne à
tergnier ont démoli c'est une centrale
edf au charbon le bâtiment s'est
effondré deux ouvriers ont trouvé la
mort quatre autres ont été blessés bruno
gex marie frichards reportage
la centrale thermique d'edf de beautor
n'est plus qu'un amas de tôles
enchevêtrées
20 mille tonnes de ferraille qui se sont
écroulés sur une quinzaine d'ouvriers il
était venu préparer le dynamitage demain
de l' usine désaffectée en cours des
démolitions que notre métier dessous
comment vous avez fait pour vos enfants
julie reçue à craquer ça fait un bruit
énorme
j'ai eu le réflexe de partir dans le bon
sens
ce que vous étiez là où j'étais derrière
des bâtiments exactement là où se trouve
votre camarade mais j'ai couru dans le
château ici peu près je voulais ce tube
est tombé à 2 m les secours une centaine
de pompiers et dix maîtres chiens les
mêmes qui avaient fait le voyage à
mexico et en arménie se sont rendus sur
place très rapidement six ouvriers ont
pu être dégagées dès l'arrivée des
pompiers trois autres ont été
transportés sur les hôpitaux de la
région deux sont décédés il reste un
homme qui luttent contre la mort
prisonniers sous plus de 40 mètres de
ferraille au coeur même de la centrale
dans un lieu pratiquement inaccessible à
l'extrémité de ce boyau
il est complètement ensevelies et en
dessous du lien en fait que l'eau du
corps qui dépassent donc les deux bras
jusqu'au bassin
en dessous il ya tellement pleuré on
voit pas et
quand on lui demande de bouger ces gens
me laissant pas et qu'est ce que vous
redoutez à ce qu'on redoute surtout
c'est que au moment où on va essayer de
dégager où on va noter coincé qui se
produisent en fait un désamorçage et qui
est et qu'on les perde la erreur humaine
l'enquète judiciaire a été ouverte pour
déterminer les causes réelles de
l'accident dans l'immédiat c'est la vie
d'un homme qui est en question
voilà les quelques petits problèmes
techniques en raison d'une transmission
immédiate c'était quasiment en direct
bono gex nous envoyait son sujet les
prisons c'est un dossier très difficile
en france le fond du problème c'est la
surpopulation des prisons trop de
détenus est donc une surveillance
difficile aujourd'hui un rapport a été
publié c'est le rapport bonne maison
sans proposition pour venir à bout du
malaise des gardiens de prison alors
nous allons revenir en détail sur ces
mesures proposées mais regardez d'abord
cette enquête de rémy roche il a suivi
un agent de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui lui a expliqué tous
les problèmes
il a 34 ans dont déjà 13 dans la
pénitentiaire 13 ans de boîte comme ils
disent entre eux
salut
françois avait d'abord travaillé à
l'usiné trop dur et mal payé ils
préfèrent aujourd'hui le salaire de 8500
francs et la sécurité d'un fonctionnaire
même si c'est sans enthousiasme excessif
curieuse emploi du temps définitivement
h est en grosse demi journée il en prend
pour six heures à chaque vacation quand
ça n'est pas un service de nuit
dans un sens et c'est bien de travailler
en demi journée parce que faut pas
oublier que c'est un travail qui n'est
pas physique mais qui est quand même
très éprouvant pour les nerfs et je
crois que à long terme on ne supporterai
peut-être pas d'être là est toute la
journée
effectuant ce travail
la maison d'arrêt de strasbourg est tout
neuf et ultramoderne pourtant déjà
problème chronique dans les prisons
françaises le personnel se plaint du
manque d'effectif conséquences trop
d'heures supplémentaires 10 les
surveillants et un fonctionnement de
l'établissement qui peut être perturbé
les gens qui sont en service et qui
travaillent sont obligés de cumuler
plusieurs fonctions à savoir par exemple
un agent qui infectait dans une unité de
vie dans un étage pendant les heures de
promenade 20 effectuer la surveillance
des promenades donc par la force des
choses les tâches se retrouve
pratiquement sans surveillance est remis
en cause notamment la sécurité
atelier si on peut régler d'abord les
problèmes qui touchent à la sécurité qui
touche à nos conditions de travail des
surveillants aux conditions de vie aux
conditions d'hygiène à ce moment là on
pourra voir ce qu'on peut faire au
niveau des tenues mais tant que ces
problèmes là ne sont pas réglés je crois
qu'il faut pas y songer et qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire à ce moment là par
exemple au niveau de la réinsertion je
crois que la réinsertion est un grand
mot dans l'état actuel des choses c'est
quelque chose c'est un vrai échec parce
que l'on demande à l'administration
pénitentiaire par exemple de réussir là
où toute autre institution a échoué à
savoir leur famille l'environnement de
l'individu ou la société en règle
générale
désabusé ces surveillants de prison qui
de l'autre côté du mur sont toujours en
quête de la reconnaissance d'un public
souvent sévère à leur égard encore
faudrait-il que leur mission soit
clairement définie si comme on le dit
elle ne consiste plus seulement à ouvrir
et à fermer des portes aujourd'hui donc
publication du rapport bonne maison avec
des propositions originales par exemple
la surveillance électronique des détenus
à l'extérieur ce qui permettrait de
désengorger un petit peu les prisons
détail de ces mesures isabelle dèche
l'air
un mot d'ordre résoudre la surpopulation
il faut incarcéré - et ce dès
l'instruction il faut individualiser les
peines de manière plus souple pour une
meilleure réinsertion ne pas dépasser un
nombre maximum de détenus par
établissement sans faire sortir aussitôt
un autre détenu à chaque fois quitte à
le surveiller à distance grâce à
l'électronique construire moins de
prison neuf gilbert bonnemaison souhaite
qu'on commence par réhabiliter les
maisons d'arrêt existantes il réduit de
3400 places de centrales les ambitions
de l'ancien garde des sceaux albin
chalandon la formation initiale des
gardiens seraient allongés un minimum de
huit mois ont leur attribuerait des
moyens efficaces de communication comme
des talkie walkie pour une meilleure
sécurité en revanche pour humaniser les
rapports internes avec les détenus la
journée de travail serait allongée d'une
heure pour éliminer les heures de pointe
des repas ou des visites de nouvelles
conventions avec les organismes hlm
devraient améliorer les conditions de
logement des surveillants en revanche le
rapport ne va pas jusqu'à satisfaire la
revendication principale des syndicats
à voir la bonification d'un cinquième de
l'ancienneté comme pour les policiers la
grève menace donc déjà dès lundi
effectivement déjà ces mesures soulève
la grogne les surveillants n'apprécie
pas et menacent de se mettre en grève
isabelle le disait réactions de part et
d'autre
nous avons l'impression d'avoir été
roulé d'avoir on a voulu arrêter ce
premier mouvement d'octobre nous avons
cessé ce mouvement nous l'avons
suspendue or aujourd'hui nous avons
l'impression que quatre mois après on
nous accorde rien de plus que qu'à cette
époque là est ce que cela veut dire que
vous pourriez reprendre le mouvement
il ya de fortes chances ce qui a été
fait non seulement sur le plan de
l'amélioration statutaire des personnels
mais également tout ce qui est proposé
sur l'amélioration est quelque chose qui
n'a jamais été fait à l'administration
pénitentiaire il faut que les agents le
prénom compte l'autorité d'état devrait
être assurée s'il reprenait le mouvement
avec les rigueurs éventuelle du sac
spécial s'ils ne font pas ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas le faire n'ont pas leur
place à l'administration pénitentiaire
et j'ajoute enfin que pierre arpaillange
le garde des sceaux lance ce soir un
appel aux gardiens de prison c'est même
un avertissement le gouvernement ne
saurait tolérer une nouvelle grève du
zèle dit-il notamment
coup d'état en amérique du sud il fut un
temps où ce titre étaient très fréquents
mais peu à peu ces pays d'amérique du
sud devienne tout à fait démocratique
voir l'argentine ou le venezuela eh bien
cette fois le coup d'état a eu lieu au
paraguay le paraguay du général strauss
nerfs le général france nerfs a été
renversé le paraguay c'est ce petit pays
au coeur de l'amérique latine un peu au
dessus de l'argentine strauss nerfs
étaient au pouvoir depuis 34 ans record
de dictature
il a été renversé donc par un autre
militaire le général rodriguez le sang a
coulé une centaine de morts selon un
premier bilan pour bien comprendre ce
qui s'est passé voici un document
exclusif dan loustallot et richard de la
fuente reviennent du paraguay
c'était il ya quelques semaines nous
assistions à l'une des dernières sorties
officielles du général président alfredo
stroessner depuis longtemps on
chuchotait cas militaire succéderait à
strophes nerfs je veux rétablir la
démocratie a dit ce matin le général
rodriguez après son coup d'état andrés
rodríguez numéro deux du régime parents
de strauss nerfs après le mariage de sa
fille avec le fils cadet du dictateur
trafiquant notoire si l'on en croit la
rumeur publique qu'il a surnommé le
général cocaïne
dictateur du paraguay pendant 35 ans a
été détrôné aujourd'hui ce fils
d'immigré bavarois son père était
brasseur à munich avait pris le pouvoir
par la force en 1954
le général rodriguez faudra-t-il comme
ce trentenaire qui avait assuré à sa
dictature un semblant de légitimité
soutenu par son parti le colorado il
avait été élu cette fois au cours de
parodie d'élection présidentielle
deuxième acte de la farce électorale
imaginé par frau snare le parlement il y
a le colorado et quelques députés triés
sur le volet pour jouer lé rôle
d'opposant le représentant du parti
libéral en bon figurant propose qu'une
manifestation sur les droits de l'homme
soit autorisée
la parole est maintenant parti colorado
parlons-en monsieur le président
de ceux qui croient défendre les droits
de l'homme
ken omnium précise amel terreau la
tierra promettent-ils a cédé pas la
terre promise qui vont nous conduire ils
vont nous entraîner dans les chemins
obscur de l'anarchie
là on entend le son du canon et le bruit
la mitraille
alors que nous nous le colorado
avec alfredo strauss
nous représentons l'autorité morale
monsieur le président et la justice
ceux qui défilent aujourd'hui dans la
rue risquent demain de défiler dans les
geôles de l'ex dictateur en 35 ans de
dictature un paraguayen sur trois a été
emprisonné
mais la colère est souvent plus forte
que la peur et l'histoire des
manifestants qui se précipitent sur les
soldats pour leur arracher caste des
matraques fera le tour de la ville comme
un haut fait de résistance
la manifestation se termine comme prévu
par le ramassage de militants
beaucoup d'entre eux vont disparaître
mise au secret sans jugement cet homme a
voulu témoigner du sort réservé aux
prisonniers politiques au paraguay
et tous le tc and youth une impression
commandes au cours de mes treize années
de prison comme beaucoup de mes
compatriotes j'ai subi des tortures
physiques et psychologiques
dans mes cauchemars je revois encore les
coups de matraque le supplice de la
baignoire et les décharges électriques
envoyés par des électrodes et que la
police avait placé sur moi
la torture psychologique
la plus atroce a été pour moi le jour où
les mots obligé à creuser sa propre
tombe
à l'occasion de la communion l'église
quand une nouvelle fois ses distances
ostensiblement le prêtre pas sans se
détourner devant la tribune officielle
seule la femme d'un officier traverse la
rue devenu un fossé entre le dictateur
et l'église l'église que le pouvoir
tente d'abattre par la violence la
calomnie et la corruption
après la prise de pouvoir du général
rodriguez il n'est pas sûr que la
dictature au paraguay soit tombé avec ce
trentenaire peut-être at-elle seulement
changé de nom
bombe et dernière étape du président
mitterrand pour sa visite en inde
troisième étape après calcutta et delhi
bombay vive et à l'heure française
aujourd'hui car 89 sera en effet l'année
de la france en inde foule fast
festivités jean-michel mercurol yvon
barbe
ce soir les rues de bombay n'était plus
une foule immense la seule rencontre en
trois jours de françois mitterrand avec
le peuple indien pour un spectacle
futuriste au bord de l'océan du savoir
faire technologique français bombay le
coeur économique et financier de l'inde
moderne le lieu choisi pour faire se
rencontrer deux cultures faire commerce
et de civilisation accroître les
échanges interactifs rappelait encore ce
matin par françois mitterrand à la
réception de la communauté française sur
un navire de la flotte un objectif
auquel on travaille ministre française
et indienne pendant tout ce voyage
l'exploration de la coopération doit se
poursuivre encore mais rajiv gandhi a
d'ores et déjà accepté l'invitation du
président français en juillet à paris
pour les fêtes du bicentenaire
pour lancer cette année de la france en
inde paris avait donc choisi laser
pyrotechnie palais et vidéo pour offrir
à la foule indienne un spectacle
sophistiqué l'espoir maintenant et que
l'avenir des relations économiques
franco indienne ne se limite pas un feu
d'artifice
au chapitre des affaires peu de choses
aujourd'hui une interview tout de même
de max théret au monde maxter et c'est
l'homme qui a été montré du doigt par la
cob dans la sphère pechiney je suis
tranquille sur la solidité de mon
dossier dit monsieur terreau est saoul
il sous-entend d'ailleurs qu'il a servi
de bouc ellis r
ça coince toujours entre le pcr ps les
discussions non-stop ont repris
aujourd'hui tantôt place du colonel
fabien tantôt rue de solférino chez l'un
ou chez l'autre les patrons discutent
entre eux mais pour l'instant rien ne
sort alors où en est on ce soir pascal
guimier
ensemble facile à dire enfin les
négociations pc ps sont sortis du
brouillard mais pour révéler une réalité
plutôt amer aux deux parties il y aura
bel et bien une quarantaine de primaire
après 13 heures de pourparlers hier
après une nouvelle rencontre aujourd'hui
au siège du pc pierre mauroy venant en
personne prêter main-forte négociateurs
les deux partenaires annoncent un accord
mais un accord du bout des lèvres un
accord qui n'enthousiasme vraiment
personne je pense qu'on aurait pu mieux
faire
et
je pense qu'il reste
beaucoup d'efforts pour que l'accord
soit appliqué
intégralement
il ya encore du travail à faire pour
parfaire la composition de ses listes
aux élections beaucoup de travail à
faire dialogue de sourds à paris à
marseille aumont et ailleurs et puis une
vingtaine d'autres villes laissées en
suspens les deux partenaires n'en sont
pas au bout de leurs peines ironie d'un
accord qui n'en finit pas en dehors
d'aboutir mais les municipales suite
raymond barre annoncé officiellement
qu'il serait sur la liste du maire
sortant francisque collomb le maire
sortant à lyon lyon une ville que nous
avons radio scoop et vendredi dernier ce
vendredi c'est lille que nous passons au
crible et comme d'habitude la bataille
politique d'abord à la mairie de lille
pierre mauroy indéboulonnable mais cette
fois il ya une vraie opposition
seulement elle arrive en ordre dispersé
olivier lerner jean cornu enquête
le jeu du petit pavé lillois se joue à
trois but de la partie occupée le
beffroi et c'est chacun pour soi bruno
durieux le premier prend la boule et la
lance
incarne la fraction la plus archaïque et
la plus sectaire du parti socialiste
alex türk le deuxième prend la lance et
la boule je pense que monsieur mauroy
est une sorte de colosse aux pieds
d'argile est encore très très très
vulnérable il faut trouver tendon
d'achille et je pense que je commence à
cerner le problème dans ces conditions
que fait la troisième
viennent à lille pour se faire une
notoriété
du desire ont prouvé que il peut être à
95 peut-être même au-delà quoi tout et
ça va faire une campagne électorale mme
qu'ils apprendront à conduire une
campagne électorale et il en faut du
temps or pour conduire une ville leurs
fonds manquants dans la page de temps du
haut de son d'effroi pierre mauroy
compte les coûts la droite s'entre
déchirent au total quatre candidats de
l'opposition se disputent le fauteuil du
maire bruno chauvière conseiller général
ex rpr ex pro nationale pierre ceyrac
ancien député front national alex türk
secrétaire fédéral du rpr du nord et
bruno durieux députés par east de la 4e
circonscription du nord les jeunes loups
se mangent pas entre eux au risque de se
prendre les pieds dans le tapis futur
que parle de candidature sauvage qu'est
ce que vous avez à lui répondre est ce
que j'ai une tête de sauvages je ne suis
pas une tête de cheval ma candidature je
la maintiens à lille pourquoi parce que
je pense que lille et peut se choisir un
maire centriste mais que lille ne se
donnera pas un maire rpr
curieux jusqu'à aujourd'hui je pensais
que les choses étaient claires nous
étions côte à côte face à un adversaire
honnêtement oui je me pose des questions
conclut des attaques violentes à la
limite
inacceptable qu'il n'est pas mon égard
et d'une certaine manière ça brasse
comme dit mon équipe si on m'attaque et
s'il m'a taxé proposé question
imperturbable pierre mauroy poursuit son
travail de maire au quotidien la
construction du centre d'affaires le
croisement des tgv dans l'île et les
zones de stationnement du centre ville
semble passionner davantage le maire
sortant que les querelles primaire de
clocher qui résonne au dehors le jeu du
petit pavé lillois se joue bien à 3 à
lille avec pour témoins 174 mille
habitants et 3200 employés municipaux
deuxième volet de notre enquête sur
l'île la perspective économique
elle est brillante pour lille avec le
tgv en effet lille va devenir un
véritable carrefour en 93 elle fera à
une heure de londres à une heure de
paris et à une demi heure de bruxelles
grâce au tgv donc conséquence incidence
agnès poirier
le tgv andré gagnon n'en veut pas il
doit passer au fond de son jardin sous
terrain dans la ville de lille les tgv
déboucheront ici dans la banlieue nord
direction calais à 240 kilomètres on a
vu nous donne la presse que dans pas mal
de régions de france me déplacer démarra
crapaud oui il passe sous les vignobles
du louvre et il va passer sur le nouveau
parc de rhodes island et nous les
habitants de la banlieue lilloise
on nous impose un tgv au rabais
la solution un tunnel trop coûteux trop
long à construire pour la sncf qui
propose une voie semi enterré leur
obsession que tout soit fini coûte que
coûte en mai 93 pour l'ouverture du
tunnel sous la manche venant de londres
bruxelles paris les tgv se croiseront au
coeur de lille à sept mètres sous terre
carrefour européen lille voit encore
plus loin tout autour de la gare et pour
cela on repoussera même le périphérique
un quartier d'affaires ultra moderne va
être créée de toutes pièces
ce quartier-là se caractérisera pas sa
modernité à cette transparence n'a même
pas son élégance et par le fait que
auront été prises en compte autant
la douceur de vivre le confort dit vivre
que les nécessités fonctionner son coeur
grand comme deux fois la défense on y
trouvera des bureaux beaucoup de bureaux
mais aussi des logements des commerces
des espaces verts une foire d'exposition
situé à quelques minutes du vieux lille
c'est le plus important projet urbain
actuel mais qui en assurera la maîtrise
mois assure le socialiste arthur
notebart à la tête de la communauté
urbaine pas question réplique-t-on à la
mairie socialiste de lille pour éviter
les querelles de beffroi on préfère
rester discret enjeux économiques mais
aussi politiques le tgv le centre
d'affaires vont bouleverser le visage de
l'île ça attendra bien après les
municipales
au chapitre politique encore ce geste
qui mérite au moins d'être signalé théo
braun ministre chargée des personnes
âgées a déclaré au journal la croix
qu'il avait refusé de toucher ses
indemnités de ministre il les a versé à
son cabinet ça représente tout de même
cinq cent cinquante mille francs par an
ma retraite ne me suffit a dit monsieur
rhône les instituteurs satisfait après
les propos de lionel jospin dans édition
spéciale hier soir sur antenne 2 le
ministre avait déclaré qu'il envisageait
d'aligner le recrutement et le salaire
des instits sur ce mes profs d'autres
informations importantes de cette
journée en vrac mais en détaille bruno
roger-petit
tchernobyl trois ans après les autorités
soviétiques ont décidé l'évacuation
d'une vingtaine de villages contaminés
selon la télévision soviétique la
plupart des personnes évacuées n'aurait
jamais été avertis des risques courus à
rester dans une région touchée par la
radioactivité
l'état des lieux après le passage du
cyclone fihri nida sur l'île de la
réunion louis le pensec ministre des dom
tom est venu constater l'ampleur des
dégâts un milliard selon lui ce qui
nécessitera des mesures exceptionnelles
en faveur de l'île sinistrée
alerte au gaz à toulon une pelle
mécanique a heurté une conduite de gaz
souterraine provoquant une explosion
suivie d'une fuite importante deux
écoles un lycée un hôpital ont été
évacuées mais aucune victime n'est à
déplorer
peut-être une bavure policière près de
cavaillon argon précisément schéma
classique un petit noyau de 17 en force
un barrage de police les gendarmes ont
la gâchette un peu rapide l'adolescent
est mort et cela pose bien des questions
patrice blais
mort d'avoir pris la fuite devant les
gendarmes à 17 ans kamel bounouara a
perdu la vie cette nuit au bord de la
nationale 7 dans une voiture volée vers
minuit il s'arrête pour faire le plein
les gendarmes interviennent mais kamel
refuse de quitter la voiture marche
arrière accrochage avec un véhicule de
gendarmerie puis la r5 prend la fuite
par dessus le trottoir un gendarme tire
sur le conducteur vingt-et-une douille
repéré sur le bitume la voiture termine
sa course de l'autre côté de la
nationale kamel est mort sur le coup
et ça revient à préciser le prévenir
voilà je trouve que c'était celle de
faire une chose pareille
l'émotion et révolte sur la place du
village les copains de kamel ne
comprennent pas bien sûr avec les
gendarmes les relations sont tendues
bien sûr kamel les avaient injuriés il
ya quelques semaines mais dans cette
affaire comment invoquer la légitime
défense moi ce que je trouve ainsi
qu'une gamme entry cet homme s'est passé
vidéo et chercheurs dans le ventre dans
le ventre une voiture vous voulez c'est
gênant tout pouvait pas le voir
pour le tuer comme ça
cet après midi la famille de kamel a
déposé plainte contre x à la gendarmerie
d'orgon pas question d'apporter la
moindre explication
sans transition le sport le tennis c'est
la coupe davis c'est parti pour la
france au premier tour elle rencontre
israël à tel aviv alors dès le premier
match noah a battu blum ça fait donc 1 à
0 pour la france dans le deuxième match
en revanche henri leconte est en
difficulté et daniel canal daniel et
bien écoutez pour la surprise la plus
agréable de cette fin d'après midi
disons qu henri leconte qui avait perdu
les deux premiers sets 6 3 6 4 face à
amos mansdorf qui est ici au premier
plan henri leconte étant au service eh
bien henri leconte que voici à redresser
une situation qui paraissait plus que
compromise puisqu'il a pris le troisième
set 6 2 qu'il a pris le 4e 6 4 et cas
actuellement les deux joueurs sont à
égalité deux manches partout on est dans
le cinquième set et ses marges d'or qui
mène un jeu à zéro henri leconte et tant
qu au service c'est la septième fois que
ces deux joueurs se rencontrent et
l'avantagé aux français qu'ils mènent
dans ce face à face avec l'ange d'or par
cinq victoires à une la france mène 1 0
après la victoire de noah et rien n'est
fait dans ce match entre henri leconte
et amos mansdorf deux manches partout 1
jeu 0 pour l'israélien le français au
service des nielles effectivement beau
redressement pour henry qui était mené
deux manches à zéro en ski championnats
du monde ce soir c'était la descente du
combiné messieurs malgré des conditions
atmosphériques difficiles alors on
attendait une bagarre zurbriggen gérard
délit en fut-il ainsi gérard holtz
la réponse est oui hervé claude il y a
eu bagarre entre marc girardelli et
pirmin zurbriggen
mais le duel a tourné court car sauver
ghana raté sa course alors que marc
girardelli l'huile a parfaitement réussi
c'est bien marc girardelli l'un des
meilleurs descendeurs actuelle il l'a
une nouvelle fois prouvé ici dans ce
passage que l'on appelle le serpent à
sonnettes un couloir de glace qui
ressemble un toboggan marc girardelli a
été plus vite que tous les autres neuer
temps intermédiaire une 42e 52e et en
bas le deuxième chrono derrière
l'italien mayer mais ce chrono lui a
permis de devenir ce soir champion du
monde du combiné c'est son deuxième
titre de premier titre il avait obtenu
en 1987 à crans montana on savait qu'ils
rares délit est un skieur est complète
il a une nouvelle fois prouvé ce soir
ligue des champions du monde du combiné
didier schmitt le français est 9e
et pour le tableau d'honneur du vendredi
soir on reste dans le sport ce week-end
à bercy le master d'escala d'un grand
mur avec des gens qui grimpe dessus dans
des situations complètement impossible
beaucoup de succès en tout cas l'an
dernier il y avait quinze mille
spectateurs en tout alors ce soir au
tableau d'honneur c'est l'une des
vedettes c'est une française elle
s'appelle isabelle pâtissier bonsoir
isabelle vous êtes déjà sur le mur tout
compris alors écouter avant de parler je
voudrais qu'on montre quelque chose
parce que les téléspectateurs vont mieux
comprendre ce que vous êtes capable de
faire c'est un document qui était tourné
à hong kong il y à quelques temps
regardez tous c'est incroyable
on regarde
my name is khan
ce secteur
et
ka sat est finie
je tends
voilà isabelle pâtissier dans ses
oeuvres alors isabelle pâtissier otez
moi d'un doute quand vous faites ça
comme ça par exemple à hong kong oui ou
non est ce que vous avez le vertige non
pas du tout jamais vous n'avez eu lieu
j'amène avait alors plus facile
évidemment parce que nous pauvres
mortels qui avant le vertige en
permanence on peut pas imaginer ça donne
des frissons dans le dos non je pense
que c'est plutôt une question d'habitude
c'est à dire depuis l'âge de 5 ans je me
ça mais bon c'est un petit peu une
partie intégrante de ma vie donc j'ai
pas pas un problème à me poser au sujet
de la hauteur je réalise ce que vous
faites c'est de l' escalade n'est ce pas
staline ya une grande différence avec
l'alpinisme c'est complètement différent
disons que maintenant il ya la
séparation entre la montagne qui se
pratique au milieu de la neige la glace
et la falaise dont qui se pratique soit
en extérieur sont à l'intérieur comme
ici à bercy parfois c'est pas un taux du
cirque aussi
c'est une compétition c'est à dire n'est
obligé d'organiser un petit peu un show
autour de ça pour que ça se rende un
petit peu plus plus disponible pour
toutes les personnes qui nous regardent
vous avez quel âge isabelle 21 et au
fait ça depuis combien de temps depuis
j'ai donc commencé à 5 ans est déjà pas
mal d'années effectivement maintenant
vous êtes une vraie professionnelle
c'est-à-dire vous gagnez de l'argent
aussi et que c'est devenu un vrai sport
professionnel escalade voilà que nous
vivons grâce à des sponsors qui nous qui
nous paie bon pour faire entre autres
des compétitions et pour avoir le plus
de retombées médiatiques possible vous
êtes déjà blessé ou pas en escalade et
goûter bonne chance pour demain merci
isabelle pâtissier merci bien voilà fin
de ce journal avant je vais vous donner
les pronostics pour le tiercé quarté de
demain ce sont les pronostics de
pierrette brès on va les voir s'afficher
tout de suite le 13 le 14 le neuf le 8
le 11 le 15 le 7 et le 5
fin de ce journal tout de suite la météo
c'est cabrol gelé vu tout à l'heure il a
disparu il va revenir vous allez voir
ensuite le dernier journal fait le
prochain rendez vous avec l'information
ce sera après apostrophe c'est henri
sannier vers 23h pour ce week-end comme
d'habitude vous retrouverez daniel
bilalian métier dur ou philippe gassot
excellent week end à lundi pour voir
ou
pas